Barbara Walters is being remembered this
morning for her many interviews with
major newsmakers and for being the first
woman to co-anchor and then anchor a
weeknight television news broadcast
Barbara Walters died Friday she was 93
years old Jamie yukas reports on Walters
long and storied career
do you feel funny crossing the Bay of
Pigs
Barbara Walters was a familiar face on
America's television sets in our country
we read that you are unstable She
interviewed every president from Richard
Nixon are you sorry you didn't burn the
tapes to Barack Obama by many accounts
your wife is more popular than you are
along with world leaders and Hollywood
stars many women see you as the perfect
man tell me something awful about
yourself Walters started in the early
1960s as writer and researcher on NBC's
Today Show but soon moved to a job in
front of the cameras thank you Barbara
Walters for all that hard work in 1976
Walters left NBC for ABC where she
became the first woman to co-anchor a
network Evening News broadcast and I'm
very pleased to be with you Harry and
during her almost 40 years with ABC she
continued adding to her list of big
interviews as a co-host of ABC's news
magazine program this is 2020 as well as
Barbara Walters specials including the
first TV interview with Monica Lewinsky
which Drew an estimated audience of 74
million people what will you tell your
children when you have them mommy made a
big mistake in 1997 Walters helped
create the view which has remained a
daytime talk show staple
when Walters retired in 2014 she told
Gail King what she was most proud of
however there's not a woman on TV today
that can't look back and say if it
wasn't you then there wouldn't be me and
that's the most important thing to you
yeah it is the most important thing to
me that that's what will continue Jamie
yukas CBS News Los Angeles